all right guys
bang bang i've got the man here himself
deli what's up man
thanks for having me tom absolutely well
i i guess uh we should tell people right
off the uh off the start
we're doing a joint podcast i did this
one time before with jason calcanis and
people loved it so we're doing a second
one
uh if you listen to the deli podcast go
subscribe to the pomp podcast
if you listen to the pop podcast go
subscribe to the deli podcast
but uh i just wanted to jump on and just
talk with you so thanks so much for
doing it
no i'm looking forward to it i'm uh i'm
a bit of a rookie to the podcasting game
but i've been listening to yours and and
picking up a few tips along the way
absolutely so let's start maybe with
your background uh
most people know you as an nba player
won an nba championship
and and kind of uh have that side to
your life but what they don't know
is uh you spend a lot of time thinking
about investing and kind of
being very intelligent strategic on that
end uh just
help people understand how did you get
to the nba first and then we'll get into
the investing stuff
yeah so i grew up in australia in a
small country town
i moved away from home when i was 16 to
go to the australian institute of sport
which is
uh olympic level training facility uh
from there went to college in california
for four years
uh and then i've played for the
national team so i've been to two
olympics for australia which
has been absolute highlights um and then
tried out for the the 2013 draft did
about 20
nba workouts went undrafted uh
got on a summer league roster with the
cavs uh then training cam and then
eventually made the team
what is it like to go and draft it right
i think when people hear that it's like
this weird thing where they're like wait
a second you end up
winning an nba championship like how do
you go from undrafted to that so what's
the feeling like when
you put all this work and you met all
the teams and then the draft comes and
goes and no one calls from it
uh it's pretty crushing really uh
because
the you know the percentage chances of
making the nba
after you go undrafted aren't very good
at all
um so you know it was
it was really disappointing i was
watching it with some close friends at
my college coach's house
um spoke to my agent soon after and he
said
you know you've got it's it's going to
be okay you're going to get another
opportunity
um to go to some league and try to prove
yourself there
and then go to training camp again and
prove yourself there and uh
teams bring in 20 players to a training
camp
there's 15 roster spots uh 13 of those
roster spots are already taken
so basically there's seven guys
competing for
two spots um you it was funny we were
getting ready in a basically a visiting
locker room
um so you knew you weren't on the team
um
going into training camp and it was a
tough grind but
makes me appreciate it every day yeah
what's the uh kind of culture or
relationship those seven guys have as
they're competing is this like a
friendly thing or is this like
at all costs i'm making this team and i
know that if i make it that means
there's
one less spot for these other six guys
uh
it's a it's definitely a weird dynamic
um but i would say
it's it's friendly that there's a sense
of camaraderie there that
you know you know you're all on the same
boat and uh
basketball is a sport where there's a
lot of player movement and you're gonna
see people
you know down the road whether it's uh
play with them that season or it could
be
five years down the line so it's
definitely competitive but
there's a sense of camaraderie there
because it's a highly stressful
situation and nobody really understands
it
apart from the the seven people in that
room yeah
um and then obviously uh you go on and
you play with
some of the biggest stars today right
with uh i think lebron was on that team
kyrie
uh j.r smith i mean there was a whole
roster full
what is it like kind of going undrafted
then signing you know pretty big
contract and getting to play
with those people and then ultimately
play for the nba championship
yeah yeah no it's um
amazing kind of feeling to go from that
to then winning a championship um
kevin love was another one on on that
team and um
so the first year was the year before
lebron had come back to cleveland
um so we actually missed the playoffs
that yeah and then
at that some league was when um you know
he announced he was coming back and
and everything changed like what our
guys on the team said
it's just like such a like a crazy
dynamic right it's like he left there
was this vacuum and then when he
announces he's coming back i think fans
see
uh like outside looking in but
are you players like all texting each
other being like wait is he serious or
like
like what is the kind of conversation
yeah i think
uh we're in vegas for some league when
the announcement happened i think it was
on espn
and then we had a shoot around or a game
day
uh that day and uh i think
the the gm came over and whispered
something to the coach at the time
david blatt and you could see his face
kind of light up in a big smile and
then they announced it and everyone's
like wow this is
pretty crazy but then i think the next
thought at least for me
was i i hope i'm still on on this team
because a lot can happen from
summer league to uh the time the season
starts and
at that point i was on a still on a
basically
year by year deal so even after i made
the team
uh in that september october time period
they could have cut me any time before
uh january 15
before my contract was guaranteed for
the rest of the season and then they had
an option for me
uh the next season uh as well so you
never really
uh have a secure place yeah
um and then last thing i wanna ask about
basketball is uh you play with jr smith
and uh my friends and i like he's one of
our favorite players mainly just because
he
you never know what he's going to do he
might come down the court and i think
there's a
famous uh lebron interview where he's
literally like that guy i'll shoot from
anywhere he just crosses half court
he'll chuck it up
uh but he seems like like super cool
nice guy or whatever was it like playing
with him
it's funny because after you know the
lebron and janus questions he's probably
the teammate
i get asked the most about and
he's awesome i mean i love jr he he
always had your back as a teammate
um he had the nickname 9-1-1 because
when the shot clock's running down you
can
you know give him the ball with two or
three seconds left and
those are the type of shots he he makes
he's a shot maker and
i'm happy he's got another opportunity
now with the lakers
yeah that's pretty cool um all right so
you're in this uh really interesting
position which is
uh your professional athlete so there
comes kind of public notoriety with that
you have a quite public
income right in terms of people know the
contracts and things that you guys sign
it's millions of dollars a year in many
cases
but you also spend a lot of time
investing and so what i want to maybe
start with is just
you know when did you start to be
interested in investing and then maybe
we'll go ask that class by asset class
but just
talk to me a little bit about you know
you spent your whole life trying to make
it to the nba
and play at a high level this i think to
many is an afterthought but for you you
take it very seriously and spend a lot
of time on it so kind of
where does that interest come from yeah
um it's uh
something that uh growing up my dad
uh my mom's a school teacher so she's
always stressed the
importance of education and then my dad
uh
is a school bus driver but now he's been
in
real estate and he's been subdividing
land for
probably the last 15 years and he's
really
tried to educate me and my sisters and
just
teach us little things along the way so
i've had that background and education
and that kind of got
me interested in in real estate from a
pretty early age
uh and then um didn't make basically any
money until
my first contract um with the cavs that
year and
and started learning about stocks and
bonds and different things and
um found a financial advisor and
and they've taught me a lot and i always
ask them a lot of different questions
and then there's just conversations that
happen in the locker room between
players and
i've always tried to pick the brain of
the older players and
the veterans because that's the easiest
way to learn is
you know from their successes or their
mistakes
things they've gone through and um a lot
of veterans
are really helpful and they want to pass
on their
knowledge to the next generation i think
that's something that's really
cool in the locker rooms in the nba um
but i guess the the main one of the main
things i'm
interested now is uh venture capital and
that's
probably happened over the last three to
four years
um i had a small allocation in my
portfolio
uh through my financial advisors and
um would always ask them questions about
what it was and then
as you start reading more about what
other players in the league are doing um
yeah the conversations in the locker
room happen a lot more around that
and that's what i've been focusing in on
the last four years or so
yeah and it feels like um this has
become much more popular obviously in
all professional sports but the nba
specifically
i think there's been a lot of kind of
media coverage on
um the teams in the bay area just
because that's kind of the the center of
tech
but um i think in conversations that you
and i have had
uh this is happening in every locker
room right like there's players who are
becoming more interested in this
um and so as you're talking to your
financial advisors
uh how much i think education
um did you get or interest did you get
in terms of just like oh if we invest in
innovation
and hold it in the private markets for
long periods of time like that'll drive
returns
versus it being more like company-led
hey that specific company i really like
and i want to invest in that company
so was it more of like i want venture
capital exposure or was it just you
found kind of individual companies and
kind of built the venture capital
exposure through the interest in
individual companies
uh i would say a little bit of both
i think early on uh you know you get
brought
different opportunities and um you know
i send it through to my financial
advisors
see what they think uh and that led to
more conversations about
you know venture capital in general um
in the offseason they
they set up a few meetings for me with
with different people in
in san francisco uh who are very helpful
and i think that's something that
i've really enjoyed is how helpful
everybody is in in the
vc industry um a lot of people
have taught me a lot of things and um
jason being one of them i've been to his
launch uh
incubator a couple times in san
francisco uh nick crocker from australia
has really helped me out and introduced
me to a lot of people over here and
i just enjoy being around people who are
trying to be their best uh in that given
field and
i find it very energizing to talk to
somebody for
30 minutes or an hour and and pick up a
lot of the knowledge that they have on a
specific subject something that
i hadn't known about before and you get
to learn from an expert for
45 minutes it's a lot of fun this is why
i like you it's because that's exactly
what i like about
the whole podcast stuff right it's just
you get to sit and talk to people and
learn from them
um you've made a number of uh pretty
cool and interesting investments
um i'll let you kind of pick which one
you want to talk about but maybe we'll
talk about like an individual deal that
you've done and kind of
the process you go through um i've kind
of gotten to see it you know firsthand
and um you surprised me i think when i
saw how much
diligence you did and kind of reference
checks and all of that but just what
you know is there a deal that you want
to talk about uh maybe good the process
yeah um i'll talk about two um
and then i'll ask you about your process
as well but
um first one a recent one is uh
levels the constant glucose monitor and
um i actually saw it on twitter um
and the eight sleep founder matteo
another company i've invested in was
tweeting about this
um constant glucose monitor uh had a
screenshot of a graph
that showed his glucose going up and
down and so i messaged him about that
just asking what it is and
um it looked really interesting and he
said he
had got involved with them um
told me what he liked about it and then
i
asked him to introduce me to one of the
founders sam uh
emailed him he sent me over some info we
got on a call
they eventually sent me one out for me
to try myself
i think after the call i had with him i
was that impressed with what they had
built so far
and and where i could see it going and
how big of an issue
um i guess obesity diabetes
is in the in the us and around the world
that
the opportunity is massive to really
help
out a lot of people and for the company
to be successful
um but i i made sure to try it for a few
days first and and really loved it i've
learned some interesting things
um around 2 p.m i i kind of dip down a
little bit but if i have a
handful of almonds um that that keeps me
pretty level but overall i was eating
pretty well so
that's one example um the other one is
it's block five which
uh you introduced me to um set up a call
with with zach and
and brian from blockfi um learn a lot
from them
and then i have a a couple of other i
guess contacts in in the
crypto industry who uh i spoke to
and messaged with and they all said
really good things about block fire
um and then i also which i think is
great for founders
um listen to i think three or four
different podcasts
on exact talking and it was interesting
to see
the growth uh over time of the company
um from just speaking to zach and seeing
the graphs but then also
going back and listening to him speak
about what they were planning to do in
the future
and then seeing that already uh in the
company i thought that was
really cool yeah it it um so
i didn't know that you were going to say
that one but on the block by one that's
the one that i got to see kind of
firsthand right
and i remember when after you got off
the call you're like hey this is
interesting
and i think most people at that point
would try to make a decision
but your process was much more look i've
got this network of
people who are professional investors
they're familiar with the company some
that are investors and some that might
not be
like let me basically leverage their you
know work right
their diligence their years of
experience
and ultimately i think that helped you
get to the point where you want to make
an investment but
um that process i think is uh not
utilized that often by uh a lot of
athletes right they kind of they want to
make the decision
and so there's this element of like um
kind of humbleness right of like hey
i might not be the expert i'm smart
enough to kind of make the decision but
let me get as much data as possible is
that kind of how you you looked at it
yeah definitely i think that's something
i've definitely got
better at because i think as an athlete
you you have a high level of confidence
and
uh you like to think it translates to a
lot of things but
um you you have to be open to learning
and
and getting the opinion of experts who
are doing this day in and day out
because
you know my main job right now even
though we're in the off season
is basketball keeping in shape making
sure my body's right for next season
um but then you know lunch time in the
afternoons
this is definitely what i like to work
on and i think
one of the the cool things about twitter
uh
is being able to dm somebody um
and ask them hey i'm looking at this
investment
and if it's a existing investor and
you're saying can you jump on the
a call for for 10 minutes and just give
me your thoughts and
um that's how i got in touch with uh
michael arrington
and he was awesome with uh you know his
feedback and
and and what he saw in bok fi and um
just general info on crypto which um you
know i'm pretty new to i'm still
learning a lot about but i think twitter
um i'm realizing
that the power of it just to be able to
dm somebody and
and get on a call that day yeah it's uh
i always joke would say it's what
linkedin should have been
right it's basically served as that uh
before i keep
pepper and youth questions what
questions you got for me yeah well i
mean what what is your
process for for looking at a new
investment i know you do
a lot of crypto stuff but if there is
something
where you're not you know uh expert or
you want to learn more
how do you go about finding uh
references
or is it the existing investors or just
people with general knowledge on the
topic yeah
so i think one probably difference
between the way that
um i invest now definitely than i used
to uh
is there's a lot more follow-on capital
and so we kind of have the ability to
write smaller checks early on work with
the founders see them execute and kind
of
build conviction over time um and so
what that allows us to do
to some degree is like we can take a
little bit more risk and be wrong a
little bit more often
because you're saving most of the
capital double down on the winners
right and so um that's different than
let's say like an angel investor who's
probably going to write one maybe two
checks into a company and then that's
pretty much the allocation for the
business
right so they've got to be kind of much
more uh
accurate right if you think of it that
way in terms of that that initial
investment
now from a process standpoint uh it also
comes out like what are you
investing in right and i think that
because we invest so early
it's just the person right like that's
ultimately all i care about um
and do they have a good idea that
actually feeds into an analysis of the
person right like
are they a intelligent person who has
a defendable thesis as to why they're
spending their time and energy on this
idea versus you know hundreds of others
how do they actually like critically
think about it so do they have a good
understanding of what other people in
the market are doing maybe
other attempts that haven't worked why
didn't they work like all of those
things
that i think investors normally ask i
just look at it through the perspective
of like is this a sound decision maker
and is this person going to be like
persistent right if they really care
about this they're going to be
persistent
and they make good decisions like we got
a shot right like that's pretty much all
you can ask for
really early on um and so part of that
ends up being a lot of kind of reference
checking or triangulating on like that
individual person and making sure that
the initial read you get through
conversation is
what other people who know them well
agree with and then
the part that i actually like is you
know block five is a great example
uh i don't remember the exact amount
that we did i think it was like 250 000
you know at a 20 million valuation or
something right so
we were probably one of the smaller
investors in some of these rounds
um initially but over time as we saw
zach and flory and
the rest of the block by team execute
then it was like oh okay like now we
want to write big checks right and
because we had the capital base to do
that we have an
advantage um in being able to almost uh
kind of de-risk it over time
uh but you know they're a perfect
example you just bet on the right people
like they were not pitching me
on uh a bitcoin rewards credit card you
know two years ago that was not part of
the conversation
but but now they just kind of figured
out what to uh what to do right
yeah and what about the i guess the
process of
um going from an angel investor
investing your own money to
um in investing out of a fund where
you're investing
other people's money what about the
process you go through
there do you have to do a lot more um
i guess diligence or you know follow up
write up a report has that process
changed much for you
yeah i think that there's uh some
similarities to some differences right
so like
um you tend to uh see and this is
uh maybe somewhat controversial view but
uh i tend to see that people are
actually
uh more conservative with their own
capital
which most people look at as a negative
right being that like oh if you invest
other people's money that means that
you're
less conservative but venture capital
specifically like we
know that the outlier returns come from
like the crazy you know very small
probability
of working type companies so when airbnb
was raising their seed round like they
had air mattresses in their kitchen in
their apartment
right like that that's just something
that seems crazy right
and so i do think that uh venture
capital is like one area
where um having like less conservatism
in the way that you think about
investing uh can be a benefit
now if you go kind of you know overboard
and yet crazy or something then it could
be a negative
so i think one there's an advantage to
that uh in terms of
uh raising other capital from other
people really what they want to see is
again they want to see good
decision-making and they want to see
uh kind of what i'll call just like
institutional organization
right and so that could literally be
done on a spreadsheet that could be done
in google docs
or it can be done like we do where
you've got a whole team and kind of a
really big
kind of robust um you know offering in
back office and things like that
but ultimately it's just like an lp is
just
wanting to know can i trust you right
like
like they have all these crazy questions
they you know have all these weird
things that they do to do the diligence
but like that's what they're trying to
get at it's just can i trust you
and if you check that box um by showing
you have a process you have you know a
pipeline you have
a way to document uh the decisions you
make and the reasoning behind those
decisions and you give good updates all
that kind of stuff then they're going to
give you money
right so if they don't trust you like
good luck
and so like i think people just kind of
make it more complex than it really is
um because they get caught in all the
details but like that's all an lp wants
it's just
you know hey deli can i trust you if i
can trust you to make good decisions and
find good deals
then why would i not give you money
right i think that's what what kind of
the the focus is at least when i think
of fundraising
yeah yeah is that um do you enjoy the
process
of fundraising money from lps or is that
it's weird um i've told my partners this
before
i hate fundraising in like everything
other than
being in the room like there there's
something about like
the actual conversation um that's like
somewhat competitive
right it's kind of like they know you're
there to ask them for money
you know you're there to ask for money
and so like but you can't just blatantly
start the meeting with like i want your
money
right so like you're almost like uh
you're playing this um
it's not really a game but like there's
definitely some balance right
yeah and and it's one where um look
these people are incredibly intelligent
right so so you want to be respectful
but they'd be the first to say you
probably have a better understanding of
like your very niche
strategy than they do who's you know
they're more allocating to the experts
right
and so you got to kind of balance that
but that part of fundraising is
super fun and just like anything it's uh
you know you go in and you ask somebody
for money and they say they give you a
lot
you know you're super euphoric and you
feel like on top of the world
and if you ask and they say no then
you're like down in the dumps right it's
like
you know same thing as basketball or
anything else it's like when you're when
you're good at it you like it when
you're not good it's depressing right
yeah pretty much pretty much yeah
because
you've got an angel of syndicate now
right yeah yeah so
um that's something that i i kind of
view as my next step
uh in the venture capital world this is
something um
you know investing in the venture stuff
is something i want to do full-time
uh when i'm finished playing which uh
i'm not planning on a being for a while
i'm seven years in and
uh body's still feeling good um but
it was something i was going to try to
do maybe in
a year or two do a syndicate and then
you know the the pandemic hits and
i'm like okay well you know the season's
on pause for a while
um if there's a good opportunity for a
company
i'm going to try to syndicate one and a
great company came along
simple water does
home business water testing
you basically order it online they mail
it to you with a box
uh with an envelope to to mail
out to whichever water testing company
uh it goes to and then they also have a
platform for labs
so um yeah i think it's a really
exciting company making that
uh market a lot more efficient so that
one came along syndicated it
um actually co-syndicated it with
peter livingston who i've invested with
on ageless
uh quite a bit he was super helpful as
were the people at angellist and
um yeah kind of got a taste for it i'm
working on
another one right now and um yeah i
think i'm gonna try to continue to do
that
and and hopefully build a track record
there that i can
by the time i'm done playing um you know
can show
potential lps down the line yeah and
what's interesting
with this is uh in the syndicates i run
a couple of them
and it's i'm gonna put capital in and
you basically can come in
alongside me and like here's why i'm
doing it right so so it's not a
having this opportunity but like i'm not
gonna put any money in
you're putting your capital and then
asking people to invest alongside you
which i think is a way better model than
if you just had like a deal it could
like somehow show it to people but
you didn't have to risk any capital
either right yeah i i think that's
a great model that the incentives are
aligned
um and yeah i think just in general the
angelus platform for
for people that are trying to learn
about venture
i think i've seen you know i've seen a
ton of deals on there
um done you know a bit of investing on
there and it just
i think helps you almost calibrate
um what's a good deal what's not a good
deal what do you like to invest in
and even if you're not actively
investing you can
join some syndicates um get some deal
for
and just learn and i think it's a great
platform for that
yeah um and in terms of the types of
companies that you're generally looking
for in the venture space
uh you seem to have much more of a
generalist view
um is that true or are there specific
things that you're looking for
uh i would say generalist um there's
no specific vertical i've found yet that
um yeah i've kind of dived
right into it i think it's more just
company by company
um and then i'll dive deep on on a
you know specific thing and i enjoy
learning about a ton of different topics
from
um you know water quality to
um crypto stuff to space satellites
constant glucose monitors it's there's a
wide range and i
i like to i think i'd like to keep it
that way
space satellites you're gonna have to
explain that one
yeah so um this was a later stage deal
but
uh basically they send up uh
micro satellites so smaller ones
and then they can basically spread them
out more
to get more accurate readings of weather
currents and different things in oceans
and because of uh the lack of planes
flying
um you know due to the pandemic
especially
early on um the quality of weather
prediction went down
which um you know i thought was really
interesting kind of side effect
yeah it's um i i forget the company
there's a company that i saw
uh right when they were starting and uh
they were shooting
like these little mini satellites into
space
and i remember just being like man we
don't know any like we're so
primitive when it comes to all of the
things that probably are going to be
true you know 50 100 years from now
right so seeing everything from you know
reusable rockets like you can just see
the innovation happening um and it feels
like that's going to be you know one of
the next great frontiers right
yeah it's like the stuff that you see in
movies sometimes girl that's
maybe in 30 years but people are
actually working on this stuff and
um it's pretty cool to see and even be
able to talk to some of them
about what they're working on but what
about you do you
i know you obviously focus on crypto but
what what do you do when you see
other deals i guess outside that
category
yeah so uh i have two standing rules one
is uh when your friends start a company
you have to invest
and really it's really because a lot of
people are the opposite
so what i'll do is i'll usually write a
small
check um but i forget who said this
somebody
gave this advice it wasn't to me
directly it was like in public uh it
might have been on twitter or
i listened to it in a podcast or
something but they basically were like
look
when your friends start a company like
you want to be
aligned and cheering for their success
it's like a great way to do that even if
you write the smallest check on the cap
table like just
having some skin in the game one uh but
they were like and then two is
you won't like want to jump off the
building if they end up building like
the next uber and you missed out
right so like whoever this person was
was basically making the argument that
like
you know upside you get to participate
downside you completely protect yourself
from right
so they were like so like you have to
invest so that's one rule
uh and then the second one is um
i started out being like very generalist
and then obviously started to focus on
bitcoin and crypto but i'll still see
things that i think are interesting
uh and i frankly i don't have a great
kind of plan as like what to do
there um i've thought about everything
from you know syndicating to rolling
funds to
just continue doing things personally um
but but i do think that
uh there's a lot of stuff outside of
crypto that's obviously one interesting
but also too is uh the types of founders
that
gravitate towards crypto are very
different than the types of founders
that gravitate towards other things
right and and there's positives and
negatives to that um
and so i think that if you believe
you're just investing in people
ultimately
like you want to have a lot of diversity
right and so it's important to
kind of still have access to the
non-crypto stuff and do
some of it even if it's not the focus um
because i think that it just kind of
balances out portfolios and stuff like
that
yeah yeah no that that's interesting
does uh
what what are some of the things you've
learned from uh your time at facebook
and snapchat that that help you today
when evaluating founders or companies
yeah um so definitely at facebook
specifically
uh i was very fortunate just to work
with um
some of the best people probably in the
world right i mean literally
there's a number of people i worked with
that had been there since the early days
of facebook like
you know first 50 employee type thing
and they were still there
so these are people who had a front row
seat and
uh you know worst argument ever would be
that they got lucky
best argument would be that they helped
build one of the most valuable companies
in the world
right and so they just had been there
and they had lasted um
and so you get to kind of see like how
do they operate right and that doesn't
mean that everything they do is perfect
but it does mean that
um they've been able to contribute in a
meaningful way to the creation of this
you know amazing business um and so when
you see that like you definitely pick up
some pattern
recognition of just like here are things
that you know the top operators do
and so when you see it again you kind of
just notice it uh
two is i think that uh for me personally
one of the things um
that i did when i was there i think i
can't remember if i was 14 or 15.
uh i spent more time
than most uh doing interviews so the way
that it works is
uh at facebook you end up um like if
somebody wants to be a product manager
they end up getting interviewed by
product managers at facebook
so there's like a recruiter and all this
kind of stuff but like ultimately
your future peers are the ones that make
the decision which is kind of a cool way
to
uh one the existing employees make sure
that the people who are joining them
like meet the standard according to them
uh but also too
is for me it was a great learning
experience i think i uh did interviews
like over 100 candidates
you know in one of those years and it's
just like you just
get to understand like good answers bad
answers in an
interview right like people who think
critically and and i've talked about it
before but it's like simple things like
one of my favorite interview questions
is you know hey deli
you uh are responsible for uh the
facebook pages team
you go home friday night everything's
great you come in monday morning and
traffic dropped 50
to the product like what do you do right
and you just kind of like give them the
scenario
and a good answer to that would be like
um
you know i would immediately uh look at
all of the dashboards and try to
identify potential reasons why
you know blah blah blah whatever a bad
answer would be like uh
i would i would um you know call an
engineer and ask him what happened
right but the great answer would be and
this literally
that was a question i just asked people
a great answer would be the first thing
i would do is i would immediately
communicate to every single stakeholder
that we had a problem
then i would go look at the dashboard
right and like and it's just like oh
this person's done this before
right like like this person is not uh
kind of academically
going through the theory this person has
been in this situation they
understand like communicating the
problem first before trying to solve it
is important because it gets all hands
on deck
and so you just you know doing enough of
these interviews you realize little
things like that and so
in evaluating founders you can play some
of the same games right you can say hey
you're running this business like what
happens if
x occurs or if a competitor does why or
or whatever
and you can pretty much tell like here's
the people who you know think critically
and soundly versus people who
you know they basically have a dream and
uh and no plan to kind of get there
yeah no that's interesting when when you
said about
how the uh the existing product managers
uh interviewed the new one like that
that would be really interesting i don't
think it's legal
uh in the nba but if you had draft
prospects come in and scrimmage with
the existing team and then the players
gave their feedback uh
that would you'd probably get a pretty
accurate uh evaluation
i i mean i didn't even know that you
couldn't do that but like that would be
one amazing like if fans could watch
that type of stuff they would love it
right because it would almost be like a
mix of um remember
uh was that the end one tour remember
that yeah
yeah and they would probably watch that
on vhs in australia
[Laughter]
but they would like bring people you
know like kind of everyday people
and they would get a play and they
weren't playing nba players but they
were playing like the
end one professional you know whatever
people uh
and those players would like pretty much
recruit
if you were the best guy in that local
city you got invited on the tour
right so it's like kind of the same
thing it's just you couldn't be on an
nba team rather than
join the end one tour yeah that's pretty
cool i didn't know that n12 did that
where they recruited people in from
basically yeah just playing against them
they and i forget uh
who did it but they would like go to
like a local town or city or whatever so
maybe they could show up to sacramento
right it's like all the best basketball
players in sacramento and all the worst
basketball players all
show up right and they basically have
like these like street runs
and you get the guys off the end one
tour
and maybe they throw you know two or
three people from the local
community in and i think that i'm pretty
sure that there was a couple of folks
who
you know they just played and everyone
was like wow that person is really good
like you should get them on the tour and
they ended up
joining that's one way to get the coal
out that's
pretty cool well the question is like
would nba players
be uh would they behave themselves if
they were playing
and they knew that like whatever
happened on the court would determine
that they would get to determine who
gets to be on the team right or would
they just like play
as my brothers call it like bully ball
right would they just be like now listen
we're the we're the pros here right uh
they're probably like uh yeah i like
this guy he just keeps passing the ball
and i get to shoot it all the time
something like that i can see that
happening but uh
yeah well one other thing i i wanted to
ask you about
is um your background in the army i mean
what what is
like i've never really heard you talk
about that i listened to your podcast
quite a bit
and and what i guess skills and
habits did you learn there that you kind
of carry forward to today
yeah um so i've obviously thought a lot
about this
uh i would say there's three things uh
that i took away from it one was
um i call it like the mortality check
which basically is this whole idea of uh
i was
20 years old and when you know when
you're 20 you think like you're
literally superman right you're going to
live forever
you are only going to get stronger
faster better looking like you know like
life's going in the right direction
um but at 20 uh i was basically thrown
into
a combat zone with guys who are older
than me so i don't remember the exact
kind of average age but they were
definitely
you know married they have kids they've
got like a mortgage at home like they're
living real life and i'm still living
like you know fantasy college student
life
um and uh in the combat zone you just
see
death and that doesn't necessarily mean
it's always you know somebody you know
well um
or even somebody that's an american
right it could just literally be you see
death of people in the local communities
and kind of all this stuff
and so i think it's just this like a
reminder like hey we're all gonna die at
some point
right and so uh when i came back i think
there was a big
shift in my mentality of like just live
life and enjoy it and like
you're just not getting out alive right
so like that
definitely um i think one like
made me not worry about all the little
things that i probably you know as a 20
year old kid thought was important you
realize
isn't um and then two it really gave me
license to like kind of go bigger
right which i think has served me well
uh and then the other two things i
learned were more like
actionable things on a day-to-day basis
uh one was just like discipline
um i was already pretty disciplined you
know played sports in college and things
like that but
uh this was a level of discipline of
like even when you really don't want to
do something
like you get home from a mission uh you
know onto the base it's late at night
and you know you're gonna turn around in
six hours and go back on another mission
or something
like you clean your weapon and the
reason you do that is because if
tomorrow you start shooting in your
weapon jams like you could die
right and so like you just learn like
every decision you make
uh if you keep discipline like ends up
putting you in a position where you can
be successful
um and then the last one was always just
like it's all about people
right so even in the army where like you
don't get to pick the people you quickly
kind of figure out okay dilly's a good
guy like you know
if bad [ __ ] happens like i want to be
standing next to him there's you know
the other guy who's like going to freeze
like maybe i don't want to be standing
near him
right and so you just kind of like start
to understand like
the people you surround yourself with
can determine a lot about your life
um and that's kind of an extreme life or
death type situation
but even just in investing or you know
basketball team whatever
that stuff really matters and so i think
that was like a big lesson learned as
well
yeah no that's really interesting i mean
on a much
smaller and less important scale i mean
i think
as basketball players you know who you
want uh
you know on the court with you when the
other team's going on a run or in the
playoffs when when a game is close
and um i guess that just builds over
time
through you know relying on people in in
high pressure
situations yeah 9-1-1 right
he'll make it he'll make it i i saw
somebody
uh was tweeting i think they made it
into a gif uh i saw it yesterday
uh he's with the knicks and he hits like
uh you know kind of a the buzzer's going
down he hits the three and he and he
turns and he's on a knee and he's got
like the windmill with his arm or
whatever
and it's just like look man that guy's
having fun so it makes sense
uh real estate you uh you obviously have
done
um a bunch of stuff in real estate
sounds like your dad
is really interested in that as well
talk a little bit just about how you
thought about
investing in real estate and kind of
what you've done whatever you want to
share
yeah so um yeah i've done a
bit of stuff with my mum and dad in my
hometown which is a small country town
and
um you know he started off i think doing
um like some smaller subdivisions
like a rental property then some small
subdivisions and has kind of
continued to to work his way up
but just i guess understanding how you
can use
you know other people's money meaning
like the bank's money to
to get a loan to add value to a certain
thing
and then either hold it um to to get
rent coming in
or to to sell it and then move that
money into another project i think
understanding how you can use
the bank um to your advantage um
is one of the big things i've learned
from him and
um yeah i think just
over time and i know we're going to talk
a little bit about
bitcoin and inflation but over time
um you know i've known they've seen
really good results
uh he always loves to tell me he's never
lost money on land
because they're not making any more of
that so
um well especially in australia right
you you know that there's no more land
yeah because you're surrounded by water
uh even though there is a lot of
land um you know obviously it's a big
country but
um yeah you just see i guess
melbourne you know the big city arm
closest to the the boundaries of it are
just continuously
expanding with subdivision after
subdivision so
you can see it i mean every time i i go
back to australia
and you are we're driving from the
airport in melbourne out to meribah
you know there's just more of melbourne
to get through before you
you know are on the country roads yeah
and i think that the point you're making
about the banks
one of the conversations we had you
basically look it's leverage
right it's intelligent leverage and if
you're smart about kind of managing that
and how much capital you put down and
and all of those types of ratios and
things like that like
it can be your friend um and it sounds
like that's you know one of the big
things that
has uh kind of caught your attention and
got you really interested in real estate
yeah and um he got me the the rich dad
poor dad book to read and and that kind
of laid out
um you know some really helpful things
uh
in a pretty easy to understand way and
um
i think it's okay you know with leverage
there's obviously risk but
um being in a smaller country town you
know you're not going to have the
the crazy price growth over time but
you have a really good rental yield that
that covers the mortgage
and then some usually so it's a pretty
stable asset to be in yeah and
uh everything that you do in real estate
in australia or you do some in the
united states too
uh i do a little bit over here um my
financial advisors have
you know some real estate funds and then
have a rental property here
but that's something that's more time
consuming
and you you need to be hands-on and
understand everything
that's going on there so because i can
you know rely and trust on my dad um
that's you know where where most of that
is for now
for sure all right let's talk about it
man inflation and bitcoin
what uh what what do you want to talk
about when it comes to this stuff
well i think for my listeners and being
my mum and dad and
my sisters who i've tried to explain to
them uh if you could just give us a
really
basic understanding of of bitcoin
why it's important um and then how
inflation gets into it yeah um
so i think the easiest way to talk about
it is just
uh first start with what is money right
money is a belief system
the reason why you and i exchange us
dollars or
any other currency is because uh we
believe
that it has value right so you're
willing to accept it in exchange for
goods or services
uh and so am i and so um you know
with that as kind of the underpinning it
then is why does somebody
trust the us dollar or anything else
well having a government back it is a
pretty damn good reason to do it right
and that stood kind of the test of time
uh for a very long time now when it
comes to
uh kind of moving forward most of those
currencies are not backed by anything
right and so
now there's this rise or popularity of
digital currencies and so
um when you think about digital currency
there's two key components there's the
technology
and then there's the monetary policy and
so just like
there's a technology and monetary policy
until let's say the u.s dollar
right there's a technology and monetary
policy to these digital currencies as
well
uh the technology is what gets all of
the uh kind of attention especially in
the media
right is people like oh it's
decentralized it's digital you know all
that
ultimately it just means that there's no
government backing it
and it means that by being a digital
currency that's based on a blockchain
uh everything's fully transparent right
and the way that i describe the
the blockchain usually is just when you
play monopoly
right if me you and two other people
play we sit down
we start with the board in front of us
we put our money
right which is kind of our account laid
out in front of us and then there's a
bank account that's kind of off to the
side
but there's no fifth player who's like
the designated banker who doesn't play
the
game right and so the reason why
monopoly works is because all the money
that's transferred
everyone can see so if you pass go we
reach in the bank we give you 200
right if i buy something right then i
give the money to somebody and because
everyone can see every transaction
there's trust right or there's
verification um and so monopoly works
that's exactly what a blockchain does it
just does it in an automated fashion so
everyone can see every transaction
and that ultimately leads to kind of the
truth being
always available um the more interesting
part to me is not the technology though
right the monetary policy i think is the
big kind of
inflection point um in terms of uh
why this is gaining popularity and so
the u.s dollar you mentioned
inflation the way that it is structured
is uh
more and more of it is created over time
and what that does is it devalues the
currency
so why do people buy real estate buy art
buy gold and precious metals right all
these different things
it's because what they're trying to do
is get out of the dollar right
if they hold dollars they will be worth
less and less over time
on a purchasing power basis so yes it
still says one dollar
but that one dollar can buy you less
goods and services than it could you
know five years ago
and so you're financially incentivized
to get out of dollars
and get into store value assets or other
types of assets
uh that's hard right so take your mom
who you said was a school teacher
we basically ask her to go to work every
day and
to be the best school teacher possible
right teach the kids and do a great job
but then we also ask her to take her
income
and go be a professional investor on top
of that and that's hard
right that's why in you know especially
the united states like
i think it's 45 of americans own no
investable assets
like there's no financial education they
don't know this stuff and so
in this system where you're devaluing
the dollar
investors are rewarded and savers are
punished right because you're just
putting dollars in a bank account saving
but
it's being devalued and so now comes
along bitcoin
and bitcoin basically has the exact
opposite monetary policy
so rather than there being more and more
of it created every year
there's just a set amount meaning that
there's only ever going to be 21 million
bitcoin
and there's a programmatic distribution
of it so every 10 minutes a certain
predetermined amount is given out into
the network um and this looks very
similar to gold right it's kind of a
sound
money meaning that um it's scarce
uh but the difference between bitcoin
and gold is that bitcoin is provably
scarce
meaning that you know exactly how much
are available
uh you know exactly how much are in
circulation with gold you basically have
estimates
but those estimates have essentially you
know drawn
um confidence from people for thousands
of years
and so i think when you kind of zoom out
you say okay there's two different types
of
currencies right there's the fiat
currencies which are
inflationary um and that's kind of the
system we live in today
right where your currency is going to
get devalued over time
and so you're financially incentivized
to buy goods and services or to invest
and if you do that well you actually can
get really rich right because you can
get out of the dollar get into assets
those asset prices go up
real estate appreciates all that kind of
stuff and you end up building wealth
but in the new system you aren't
required to buy goods and services or to
invest you can simply save
and what you're doing is you're saving a
scarce asset
and so over time that actually becomes
more and more valuable
in us dollar terms right so it's gone
from you know fractions of a penny
11 12 years ago to today it's worth you
know 12 000
or whatever it is and so i think that's
like the the big difference is just
a digital currency has a different
monetary policy than the fiat currencies
the debate is just which one's better
right and kind of you know how does that
happen
but i think that's really the big
difference yeah no thank you for that
and then
i'll just ping off a few questions that
they've been asking me because you'll be
able to answer them better
um why is bitcoin like the
cryptocurrency like as bitcoin was
created
and has had a rapid rise um you know why
couldn't there just be another
crypto come in and take its place yeah
so
uh two aspects to the answer here so
first aspect is
um there's i don't know five or six
thousand like
digital assets now there's only a
handful that actually trying to be
money right so bitcoin uh would like to
be the
standard right or the global reserve
currency uh there's others like
um you know ethereum or ether now is
trying to be money and a couple of
others but
ultimately uh the competition is let's
call it maybe among
15 digital assets that uh would like to
be money
but remember that money is a belief
system and so just as
facebook becomes more and more valuable
as more people join their social graph
or their social network
right because there's more people to
connect with there's more content you
kind of get tied into it
money has a network effect as well and
so the more people that use
the same money and believe in the same
money the stronger it becomes or the
more valuable
it becomes and i think that bitcoin's
advantage was one
it was first two it was able to
uh gain adoption with a very specific
type of
person who had you know very long-term
view around sound money
and the problems in the legacy system uh
but then three is just now we're at the
point where
it has the biggest network effect and so
it's got the most belief behind it right
and the market has kind of determined it
to be the
quote most valuable and so if it fails
i'm of the belief that actually another
one won't be able to be successful
and what i mean by that is you know in
venezuela the bolivia failed
if the venezuelan government comes out
and i was like oh sorry guys like we
messed that one up but like here's our
next
one people are just like nah you got us
once like you're not
we're not trusting you a second time and
so i think like bitcoin's a similar
thing here where
uh this idea of like a decentralized
non-sovereign currency
people are bought into it right now and
from a mindshare standpoint
if it failed i don't think somebody
could create another one it'd be like oh
sorry we messed up the first one but
like here's the next one right so i
think bitcoin's kind of the shot
um and so far so good but that's kind of
how i look at it
what would you say the the biggest
threats are
to bitcoin um not being like a [ __ ]
another crypto
passing it but why would it not become
you know uh successful
yeah so i think that um the number one
like
most serious threat to it is what i call
a self-inflicted wound
so basically there's you know uh
software code being written and runs the
bitcoin network and it's constantly
being
updated and that process is very
methodical and intentional
because there's you know 200 plus
billion dollars of market cap to protect
uh but if at some point there was a
software bug that was introduced
that could cause catastrophic problems
right and so obviously the development
process tries to and has successfully uh
for a long time prevented that from
happening but that to me is like
you know risk number one the second risk
is uh there could be uh some sort of
ownership ban right so the united states
you can't shut it down
because it's decentralized so what they
could do is they could basically say
we're going to ban
ownership in the united states now that
would be short-term very negative
for the asset i personally believe
that other countries that you know are
uh
frenemies with the us so kind of the
russians and china's of the world
they may actually say oh wait you guys
are explicitly saying you're not going
to use this thing like
we want to get off the u.s dollars like
we'll use it right and kind of it
actually drives adoption over the long
term
but i do see that as a risk obviously
you know if you're in the united states
or in australia and your government says
hey we're going to ban ownership like
that's not good
right i think most people generally want
to comply with the law
and then the third thing is uh i do
think that there is
um potentially in the future risk around
like
a quantum computer or you know some sort
of like 51
attack type thing where just somebody
gets a superior computer
now what i always tell people is like
one i don't think we're anywhere close
to that being developed
but also two like i don't know let's say
that you stopped playing in the nba
and you're the one who creates the
quantum computer right and i said to you
what all the things in the world that
you can use your quantum computer for
like attacking bitcoin's network is
probably not very high
on the list mainly because once you
attack the network
and it's been violated or someone you
know it's known that it's no longer
decentralized
it kind of becomes worthless right so
it's not like you could like
go and steal all the bitcoin because
then those bitcoin would just be
worthless
so if like you have a quantum computer
there's way other you know way more
important and
much more kind of productive profitable
things you could do than go attack the
bitcoin network
unless you just wanted to destroy it but
i just don't see that as like
an actual kind of high probability risk
right now
yeah what what about um like a few main
players um getting enough bitcoin where
they can basically
control the price um so
there's people who would uh say so the
hardcore bitcoiners would say one
bitcoin equals one bitcoin right similar
to one us dollar equals one us dollar
now on a purchasing price standpoint we
know that that's uh kind of a nuance
um but from a u.s dollar value right so
today bitcoin's at about 12 000
um there probably already has been some
price suppression
right so if you go back to 2017 uh
ballpark it went from like a thousand
dollars to 20
000 at the end of the year um i if i
remember
correctly uh there was i think it was
futures contracts got approved first
so basically there was a um kind of in
the legacy finance world there was a
derivative introduced that allowed you
to short bitcoin
so pretty much it was long only and so
what were people doing they were going
long
right and everyone was kind of seeing
that their uh
portfolio increase in value well the
high
for bitcoin in 2017 and still the
all-time high till today
was right before it was like the day
before two days before
that derivative was introduced and so
this whole idea of like now there's more
equilibrium in the market
because there's people who can go long
and go short
so that was kind of step one the second
thing is like there's been
plenty of price suppression i think even
some of the us banks got in trouble
uh in the gold market for example right
so like this stuff happens and markets
all over the place
um i keep telling myself that like it's
still so small it's only 200 billion
dollars i think gold's like eight or
nine trillion
right so like it probably just isn't
that interesting to them yet
when it starts to go up i think you'll
see you know some of the big boys like
hey wait a second um but but i don't
think we're there yet
yeah and then speaking of where where
it's going like
where and i know we've discussed this a
little bit before but and
end of next year where where do you see
it going and what would have to happen
for it to get there yeah so structurally
um you know as early as like summer of
last year
uh it became i don't want to say obvious
but like it became higher probability
that
uh we were kind of late cycle in the
macro environment meaning that
um you know we had been on this like
really long 10-year bull market in
public equities
uh and there were starting to be just
warning signs
right and not necessarily signs of like
hey the market's gonna tank tomorrow but
just
you saw things like inverted yield
curves you saw you know very high per
a high number of ceos leaving their jobs
you saw these like gyrations or market
breakdowns
in the repo markets like just things
where you're like okay we're getting
towards the late end of
this bull market when it turns over like
that's not going to be good and so you
start to think okay when you end it
up going into a recession or a
depression or what you know whatever
what can people do and so governments
naturally want to step in and help
right so they can basically manipulate
interest rates or they can print money
and what they did with the interest
rates is uh they're gonna drop them
right and so uh i i was writing last
summer about like hey they're gonna drop
them
you know pretty aggressively was
basically my thought process i didn't
think that they would go to zero but i
think they thought they would drop it
and then they're gonna have to print
money i thought you know again
i don't know a couple hundred billion
maybe you get to a one trillion but like
they're not going to print three
trillion right and so
you know fast forward to now like this
whole covet 19 thing
has accelerated a lot of this right and
did i foresee a global pandemic no
i don't think anyone really did um but
it definitely kind of uh
was the pin that popped the bubble right
to some degree and so
what we thought would happen in the
macro environment happened right they
had two emergency rate cuts drop rates
to zero
then they printed money at an incredible
rate you know historic levels of
quantitative easing
and all of that happened almost
simultaneously from a timeline
perspective with this bitcoin having
which is basically the daily incoming
supply of the assay got cut by 50
in may of this year right and that's
programmatic and so
what i was talking about last year was
like this if they cut rates print money
and having occurs all around the same
time it's like rocket fuel
and so now we sit here and we're like
okay well all that happened
right and so you know we can sit and pat
ourselves on the back or we can look and
say like
what was the financial performance and
so as we're sitting today i looked this
afternoon
uh bitcoins up about 70 to 75
since the beginning of the year right so
it literally started the year at one
point it dropped 50 percent which is you
know super scary for folks
uh but now it's up um so that it's a 70
um kind of up on the year and it's up 45
since the having and so like the thesis
is quote-unquote playing out
now to answer your question directly if
you kind of continue extrapolating out
what we thought was going to happen is
we believe that bitcoin is just kind of
right online to end up hitting a hundred
thousand dollars by the end of next year
which at twelve thousand dollars today
is a pretty big price jump
um but you know that's kind of our
conviction
everything we're seeing so far is like
we're still on track for that
uh we'll see what happens yeah
and and then i guess playing into that
um
i know you've probably talked a bit
about it but a company
uh converted their cash balance
sheet uh listed on the they're listed on
the nasdaq
i believe they converted their cash to
bitcoin
what uh do you think of that and then
what do you see that doing to
bitcoin then other companies that are
looking at this and saying
is this you know a viable option
yeah so uh companies micro strategy and
uh
i won't get the numbers exactly right
but they had about half a billion
dollars
um in terms of uh capital decisions to
make and so what they decided was about
250 million dollars they put into
bitcoin
uh and then they basically held a uh a
250 million dollar capital raised by
selling some shares
right it's kind of the over generalized
uh description
um the 250 million dollars in cash
going into bitcoin is the first
publicly traded u.s company to decide to
do this
now there's two things that you could
say one is
there's a lot of people who are just
like oh there's some you know
entrepreneur out there or ceo
who's trying to capitalize on the
excitement around bitcoin
they're going to do this a bunch of
people are going to go buy their stock
and like it's more of like a stock
manipulation game or kind of riding the
hype cycle
i went and i read the press release i
read everything that the ceo talked
about in terms of why he was doing it
he's a bitcoiner like this is not uh i'm
trying to you know just ride a hype
cycle i mean
word for word what he described in the
uh
press release is the bitcoiner's
argument against inflation and
quantitative easing
and he basically said look i'm worried
that the dollar is going to get devalued
therefore i can't hold dollars so i need
to get into something else and i've
chosen bitcoin as our reserve asset
we'll see what happens right but i do
think that a nasdaq-listed company doing
this to your point
opens the door now uh nobody wants to be
first
a lot of people like being second third
and fourth right and so i don't know
when that'll happen
but um you know and the company by the
way was i think a 1.2 billion
evaluation company so it's not like it
was you know some you know 50 million
kind of penny stock right it's a billion
dollar business so i i tend to think
that um
you know it'll be a positive sign long
term yeah
what do you think about it uh i mean
i think it's really bullish for bitcoin
because
i mean if you if you have a publicly
traded company i mean you know if it
doesn't go well
that guy's probably getting fired right
um
but now other companies if they
don't at least look at it or talk about
it
you know their shareholders or people
are going to be
asking questions if it does happen to go
to you know 100k
by the end of next year so um i think it
definitely opens up
some interesting conversations that um
you know i'd love to be on
the fly on the wall and one of the next
board meetings at some of these big
companies
uh what about uh warren buffett
and berkshire getting into gold um which
i believe they haven't done before and
do you see that
as or getting involved in gold is a bit
of a
gateway to getting into bitcoin because
they
you know try to perform the same
function really
yeah um so i recently wrote about this
and so uh
i'm probably gonna sound like a nerd
because i know all these uh weird stats
but uh it ultimately breaks down to um
warren buffett has historically been
very anti-non-cash producing commodities
so gold being the the big one
um he's just said look it just sits
there right it doesn't produce cash
and he really likes cash flow um so
in order to get the exposure to gold he
didn't go
buy gold he bought a gold miner which is
kind of interesting or he still bought a
business they're just in the business of
gold
which is almost like i feel like there
was like a midnight negotiation inside
of berkshire like
we got to get exposure to gold he's like
we're not getting gold but you could buy
a gold company
right so i think that was kind of the
first thing is like he still stayed with
his principles of buying cash producing
business
but it is ultimately dependent on on the
performance of gold
uh the second thing is like his
portfolio is struggling right now
right so i think it's seven of the
uh 10 of his 10 largest holdings are
financial services businesses
and i think all six of the seven or
seven of them i can't remember
are all down like double digit
percentages so he's actually doing it
pretty bad and so those financial
services on the average
uh drawdown is like 20 to 25 percent
uh this year but then he's got these
other businesses uh three of his top ten
holdings
are non-financial services and they're
up like 15 to 17 percent something like
that
and most of that's driven by apple so
it's a technology company
so warren is in this weird position i
think where if you look at the portfolio
he's
held on to a lot of like what i'll call
old school businesses right they're not
the big tech companies and whatever
and he's publicly stated over and over
again like he's not the guy who
understands tech right in terms of like
the first one he's 89 years old all that
kind of stuff
so he kind of changed his mind on the
whole gold thing
but he's still lagging because he's kind
of investing in like the old school way
yeah i just don't see him buying bitcoin
no matter you know if he lives to he's
120 i just don't think that he's gonna
do it
um what'll be interesting is you know
the guy's
been an absolute legendary investor
probably the best to ever do it
uh he's amassed this incredible fortune
at some point he's gonna hand it over to
other people
and so kind of like what happens once
he's not making the decisions right
whether he's alive or not but just like
when he's not making the decisions
anymore
like i think it'd be a pretty big moment
if berkshire hathaway bought bitcoin
right i i just don't see that happening
anytime soon
if for whatever reason that happens in
the future
i mean what what do you think happens to
bitcoin
well when he bought barrick gold uh i
think i saw today
it was up uh at least this morning it
was up like 10 12 percent
right and so like yeah this is obviously
you nor i am giving any kind of
financial advice or anything like that
uh and i have no clue what gold miners
are trading
and kind of if that's a normal movement
whatever but like
people follow him right so when he makes
a decision people are like oh i'm just
gonna do what the the smart rich guy
does
right and so i think that uh it's only
would be a positive it's just
you know what what's the impact i have
no clue
yeah yeah and then uh you talked about
gold being a non-income producing
asset um i think a lot of people and i
was one of those as well that thought
bitcoin was
was the same you know you kind of just
buy and hold it and hope it goes up
uh over time but then uh you told me
about block fire
and uh you could earn interest on your
bitcoin almost like a term deposit
um can you tell tell people a little bit
about how that works
yeah so you gotta remember that cash is
also a non-cash producing asset for the
most part right so if you just hold
dollars it's not like
you know more dollars just appear out of
anywhere and we all
do that right so i think that um it's a
question of just like okay how do you
turn a non-cash producing asset into
an interest-bearing asset right and so
uh what most people do
in the traditional world is they'll go
deposit in their checking account
uh or they'll buy some kind of treasury
or whatever but let's just say the
deposit in the bank account
the bank takes those dollars and they go
lend them out on the back end
and sometimes they can lend them out you
know five six seven times per dollar
uh with leverage and so the bank earns
a rate of return for those loans so you
know i'll make up numbers let's say they
earn three percent
uh and they turn around and they say you
know hey deli you're such a great
customer we're gonna pay you 0.03
percent
and so like the spread right that 2.97
difference they keep and it's a great
business for the banks right
but you make like minuscule uh interest
and whoever is the borrower obviously
got to borrow capital so
there's a whole kind of financial system
based on the deposits that go into a
bank
block five basically is doing the same
thing but for crypto so
you deposit bitcoin a stable coin uh
ether they got a couple others
uh they take it and they basically lend
it out to people uh those people pay an
interest rate
um and the difference is that block five
pays a very high percentage of what
that revenue is back to the user so um
yeah don't quote me on it but i think
it's like bitcoin's like six percent
interest
uh the stable question like eight point
six percent
like these are very high rates of return
and so what it does is it looks very
similar to what happens in the legacy
world it's just not with dollars now
it's with these digital assets
right so you know there's risk at your
bank there's obviously risk
in the crypto world the legacy systems
de-risked a little bit with fdic
insurance right that hasn't come to
crypto yet so i always just tell people
like
the mechanism's the same go do your
research don't go put 100 of your money
in one bank don't go put 100 of your
money you know in block fi
um but but i do think that in both
systems what you're doing is you're
trying a non
uh you know cash producing asset and to
earn interest now and so i think that's
why you know block five is interesting
and
obviously why people put money in the
bank too
yeah yeah what got you excited about
blockfi
uh i think apart from like the crazy
growth
um talking to zach um
i think you know as an investor or just
you know holding cash right now um you
you're kind of looking for
a place to put it and with uh the stock
market
going crazy you know it doesn't seem
to me like it's uh a great place to put
it right now i don't know how much more
upside it it has um you know
putting it in a bond like uh i wasn't
really
you know too too interested in that and
then when you said you could get
you know six percent um return in in my
head
i was like well even if bitcoin goes
down
six percent i'll be even on the year
that's one way i looked at it
um but then it's like you're you're also
getting all that
upside potentially down down the line
and
um even if you know it spikes like it
did in 2017 and then comes back down
you're still
earning interest on on the way up um
which i
thought was really interesting yeah i
look
you uh we're gonna make you the
spokesperson you uh you nailed it
and then i i know we're almost done here
but what what do you have planned the
next
five to ten years what are your goals um
that's a great question i don't really
do uh long-term goals
um i think part of it is uh i have two
rules in life
the first being uh if i ever do
something that i don't have fun with
uh i stopped doing it so you know i'm
having a blast doing
everything from the bitcoin stuff to the
content whatever uh if one day i wake up
and i'm just like i don't want to do
this anymore i
literally will create a video and just
like that was an awesome run guys see
you later
um so i think that that's always kind of
the back of my head
um and the second thing is uh i focus
much more now on like who i'm doing
things with
more so than like what i'm doing uh
which sounds kind of weird but
just uh i found the people you
surround yourself with end up like
dictating a lot of it
right so i just want to be around like
smart people that i
enjoy being around and they enjoy being
around me and i respect them and
and uh i tend to think that like you
just kind of figure stuff out as you go
so it's like just get the right people
you know it's kind of like a team right
yeah if you get the right guys on the
court
play go play basketball like magic
happens right and i think that's you
know friend groups are
very similar so it's more about like who
i'm doing it with more so than like what
we're doing
yeah uh me uh
i mean hopefully the olympics go ahead
next year i want to win gold medal uh
for the aussie national team we finish
fourth in rio which is
the worst place to finish in the
olympics uh
and then try to win another nba
championship
uh keep playing for as long as i can and
then
run a few more angelus syndicates put up
a track record
and then uh get it get more into this
when i'm done playing
how many more years do you think you can
play
well how okay
so i'm still pretty young 35
is that uh i always said 40
but maybe i don't know i've got a nine
month old son now and
he's a lot of fun and i it is a lot of
time on the road so
uh i would say 35 to 40 range we'll
i'll evaluate it when i get there all
right is there anybody
who i guess jordan came back pretty when
he like this
what the third time he came back the
second time he came back or whatever but
is there anybody in recent history
that's played
uh kind of upper 30s into their 40s
carl ballon maybe yeah carl malone
i mean jamal crawford just turned 40
he got signed by the nets i mean
lebron's 35
i think and he's you know good could win
the mvp and
uh obviously he's a anomaly but i think
uh with sports science now and you know
taking
care of your body for a long time it
kind of adds up and gives you
those extra years on the end of your
career for sure
all right i get asked you the last two
questions
who do you who do you think is going to
be the mvp
oh uh you make me pick between giannis
and lebron
uh i think it's a coin flip because
i think lebron has the has the
momentum around the story as well and
um i think everyone in sports world
loves a good story but
um yeah one of those two guys
one of those two for sure i think okay
uh who do you think was the nba
championship
uh
i think either one of those teams i
think i think milwaukee is going to come
out of the east
i think i think the lakers are going to
come out of the west uh
but i think it's going to be a a tough
series i think between the clippers
and and the lakers and then also the rap
the raptors and uh milwaukee i'm looking
forward to watching both of those
if the lakers in milwaukee meet you
think you think lebron can take it
i i would never bet against either of
those guys
um you know and especially uh
just you know seeing him come from 3-1
down
what he's done is just um i would never
ever bet against him
i i uh uh i had forgotten already
that's how crazy 2020 had been i was on
the phone with a
a friend and he's a big toronto raptors
fan and so we were talking about lebron
and lakers whatever
and he's like yeah like i just think
that like going back to this idea of a
story he's like
and then you know you get lebron going
and winning at a third team
kobe like and he's trying and i was like
oh wow like
i literally had forgotten that that
happened this year right
and not that i forgot that the event
happened just that it was in 2020.
and so you you start to like put it all
together like that would be a really
cool story to see happen but uh yeah
it's a lot of basketball to play between
here and there
i know that's uh looking forward to
watching it's good to have it back on
absolutely um all right guys before uh
before
i let deli go if uh if you listen to
pomp podcast go listen to
the deli podcast he was real original
with the name so it was i
i went from here and uh and vice versa
where can people find you on the
internet
uh twitter at matthewdally um
i went instagram youtube um but probably
probably twitter's best
angeles cindy just make free sign up
there
go get go check out his syndicate uh it
is definitely worth
worth looking at there's a bunch of
folks here who are accredited investors
listen to the podcast
uh there's a lot of athletes who are
trying to invest but uh but deli i've
literally seen the process firsthand he
knows what he's doing
i'm so excited to see what other deals
he finds but uh thank you so much for
doing this man this is a blast
yeah thanks paul appreciate it a lot of
fun